Musique intrigante
Gazouillis d'oiseaux
-En 1940, c'est à des milliers
de kilomètres de son pays natal
que vit Léon Trotsky.
...
Il fut l'un des hommes
les plus puissants
de la révolution russe
avant de devenir un paria
dans son propre pays.
Pire,
un homme à abattre.
Chassé de Russie
puis d'Europe par Staline,
il a trouvé refuge au Mexique,
l'unique pays au monde
ayant offert l'asile politique
à ce célèbre apatride.
Musique mélancolique
...
Trotsky, de son vrai nom,
Lev Davidovich Bronstein,
mène à Mexico une existence modeste
entouré de sa femme
et de son petit-fils.
...
Malgré les tourments de l'exil,
Léon Trotsky continue
à vouloir changer le monde.
...
Sans jamais désarmer,
il consacre la plupart de son temps
à défendre ses idées,
multipliant les attaques
envers le régime stalinien,
et visant Staline lui-même.
Musique pesante
Toute sa vie,
Trotsky a joué avec le feu.
Mais contester ouvertement
le pouvoir de Staline équivaut
à signer son arrêt de mort.
...
Et dans l'ombre,
un assassinat se prépare.
Ramon Mercader
sera le bras armé de Staline.
...
En ce printemps 1940,
Léon Trotsky n'a plus
que quelques mois à vivre,
et il le sait.
...
Rafales
Crissements de pneus
...
Musique intrigante
En 1940, Ramon Mercader
séjourne officiellement à Mexico
pour affaires,
muni d'un faux passeport canadien.
...
En réalité, il est espagnol,
et c'est un agent en mission
pour les services secrets
soviétiques.
...
Mercader évolue sous les ordres
de l'officier Pavel Soudoplatov,
chef de l'administration
des missions spéciales,
Autrement dit, des sabotages,
des enlèvements, des assassinats.
Soudoplatov a été chargé par Staline
d'organiser l'assassinat de Trotsky.
Cette mission
est baptisée opération Canard.
Et pour accomplir
ce projet criminel,
Soudoplatov peut compter
sur l'efficacité de ses services
et sur la détermination
de Ramon Mercader.
Musique douce
...
A Mexico, Trotsky poursuit
ses activités.
Il travaille d'arrache-pied
à sa biographie de Staline.
Léon Trotsky est un homme
pour lequel défendre ses idées
est un combat de chaque jour.
...
Jamais il ne renoncerait.
-Durant 43 ans
de ma vie consciente,
j'ai toujours été
un révolutionnaire,
et durant 43 ans,
j'ai lutté sous la bannière
du marxisme.
Si je devais tout recommencer,
j'essayerai d'éviter
telle ou telle erreur,
mais le cours général de ma vie
serait inchangé.
Musique haletante
...
-Dans la nuit
du 24 au 35 octobre 1917,
les Bolchéviques assiégeaient
le Palais de l'Hiver
à Saint-Pétersbourg
et s'emparaient du pouvoir.
...
Lénine présidait
le nouveau gouvernement.
Trotsky accédait
aux plus hautes fonctions
de l'Etat.
Pour défendre le nouvel Etat
révolutionnaire,
il fallait une armée
entièrement dédiée
à sa cause.
Trotsky créa l'Armée rouge,
et se jeta dans l'action,
sillonnant le pays
à bord de son train spécial
pour diriger ses troupes
et faire triompher
la révolution bolchévique.
...
Propos en russe
Pendant que sur le terrain,
Trotsky se forgeait
une stature de héros,
Staline intriguait à Moscou
pour l'évincer
à la première occasion.
Des cloches sonnent.
Le 21 janvier 1924,
le peuple russe tout entier
pleurait la mort de Lénine.
Ce jour-là, Trotsky se trouvait
à mille lieux de Moscou,
dans un train filant
vers le Caucase,
contraint par ses médecins
à un repos forcé.
Le train siffle.
Léon Trotsky
était le seul dignitaire du parti
à ne pas assister aux funérailles.
-La nouvelle de la mort de Lénine
se répandait rapidement par ondes.
J'obtins la liaison par fil direct
avec le Kremlin.
J'eus cette réponse :
"Funérailles samedi.
"De toute façon, n'arriverez pas.
"Conseillons suivre traitement."
En réalité, les obsèques
n'eurent lieu que le dimanche,
et j'aurais pu parfaitement
arriver à temps
à Moscou.
Si invraisemblable
que cela puisse paraître,
on me trompa sur la date
des funérailles.
-Tenir Trotsky
éloigné de Moscou
le plus longtemps possible
et le discréditer
aux yeux des Russes
permettait à Staline
de garder les mains libres
pour avancer ses pions
vers le Kremlin.
Car si le testament
de Lénine
était ouvertement défavorable
à Staline,
il ne désignait pas pour autant
Trotsky comme successeur.
Trotsky, qui était sûr de lui
et de son pouvoir,
ne rentra à Moscou que trois mois
après la mort de Lénine.
Il avait toujours éprouvé
un grand mépris
pour le camarade Staline
et ne pouvait envisager
d'être évincé
par un bureaucrate inculte.
-Il me répugnait
par les traits de caractère
qui ont fait ensuite sa force
dans la vague de décadence.
Etroitesse des intérêts,
empirisme,
psychologie grossière,
un singulier cynisme
de provincial.
Musique pesante
-Les deux hommes s'opposaient aussi
sur l'idéologie révolutionnaire.
Trotsky prônait
une révolution mondiale,
Staline voulait s'en tenir
à la révolution russe,
qui était désormais achevée.
Musique intrigante
En 1924,
l'Union soviétique
avait besoin d'être reconstruite
après plusieurs années
de guerre civile.
Dans ce contexte,
les membres du parti
choisirent Staline
au détriment de Trotsky,
qui risquait d'entraîner le pays
dans de nouvelles batailles.
Devenu chef suprême,
Staline retira à Trotsky
toutes ses fonctions :
chef de l'Armée rouge,
membre du Comité central,
membre du Parti communiste.
A cette époque,
les exploits de son rival
étaient encore trop éclatants
dans l'esprit des Russes
pour que Staline prenne le risque
de le faire éliminer.
De façon inexplicable,
Trotsky ne livra jamais
de bataille armée
pour reprendre le pouvoir.
-On m'a demandé plus d'une fois,
on me demande encore souvent :
"Comment avez-vous pu perdre
le pouvoir ?"
Cette question montre
que l'interlocuteur se représente
assez naïvement le pouvoir
comme un objet matériel
qu'on aurait laissé tomber,
comme une montre ou un carnet
qu'on aurait perdu.
Un train siffle.
-Durant toute son existence,
faire la révolution fut
la préoccupation majeure de Trotsky.
Une quête obsessionnelle
dans laquelle il entraîna
toute sa famille.
Musique mélancolique
...
Dans l'adversité, Trotsky a toujours
été entouré de sa famille.
Depuis leur rencontre à Paris
en 1902, sa compagne,
Natalia, est son ombre fidèle.
Elle soutient
son combat révolutionnaire
et l'accompagne
dans tous ses exils.
Natalia lui a donné deux fils,
Lev Sedov et Sergei Sedov.
Comme son père,
Lev Sedov était fou de politique.
...
Sergei, lui,
n'aimait que les mathématiques,
la littérature et le cirque.
...
Il a eu aussi deux filles,
nées d'un premier mariage,
Zina et Nina,
qui ont toujours été en adoration
devant leur père.
Musique intrigante
A Mexico, en 1940,
Ramon Mercader attend les ordres
de Soudoplatov.
Né à Barcelone en 1913,
Mercader est issu
d'un milieu favorisé,
à la fois par son père,
qui appartient
à la bourgeoisie industrielle
catalane,
et par sa mère, Caridad,
issue d'une famille bourgeoise
d'origine cubaine.
...
Ramon est très proche de cette mère
qui affectionne l'alcool
la drogue et les amours libres.
Et lorsque Caridad
se lia au Parti communiste,
il la suivit dans ses combats.
Après avoir vécu
dans la haute société
et fréquenté
les écoles pour élite,
Ramon changeait brusquement
de destinée.
Il s'enrôla d'abord
dans les jeunesses communistes,
puis, au début de la guerre civile
espagnole, en 1936,
il s'engagea aux côtés
des républicains.
...
Les Soviétiques
étaient présents en Espagne,
où ils soutenaient
les républicains
contre les franquistes.
Parmi eux, un agent secret
était très actif.
Koltsov, c'est lui qui recruta
Caridad et Ramon Mercader
pour le compte des services secrets
soviétiques.
...
Coups de feu
Caridad devint la maîtresse
de Kolstov.
Ensemble, ils décidèrent
d'un projet diabolique :
faire de Ramon Mercader,
le fils de Caridad,
l'assassin de Trotsky.
Musique intrigante
D'un commun accord,
Kolstov et Soudoplatov
décidèrent d'intégrer
la mère et le fils
à l'opération Canard.
-J'ai fait la connaissance
de Ramon Mercader,
un jeune lieutenant qui venait
de rentrer d'une mission clandestine
derrière les lignes de Franco.
J'avais appris que son frère aîné
avait perdu la vie
en allant se jeter,
après s'être attaché des grenades
autour du corps,
sous un tank allemand
qui fonçait
sur les républicains.
Sa mère, Caridad, avait été blessée
au cours d'un raid aérien.
...
-Le recrutement de Ramon Mercader
lançait la phase opérationnelle
de la mission contre Trotsky.
...
Gazouillis d'oiseaux
Depuis sa jeunesse,
Trotsky pouvait compter
sur son talent de journaliste
et d'écrivain.
Au cours de ses exils,
l'écriture lui fut d'un grand
secours moral et politique.
Il écrivit plusieurs oeuvres
importantes :
"Ma vie",
"Histoire de la révolution russe",
"La révolution trahie".
Ses livres,
traduits en plusieurs langues,
lui offraient
une efficace tribune internationale
et lui assuraient des revenus.
Car malgré son isolement,
Trotsky n'avait aucune intention
de laisser Staline le gommer
de l'histoire soviétique.
Il ne renonçait pas non plus
à sa révolution mondiale.
En plus de l'écriture,
il avait le talent d'entretenir
un réseau international.
Il avait toujours été en lien
avec les intellectuels
et les personnalités
de son époque.
En 1928, après avoir privé Trotsky
de tous ses pouvoirs,
Staline le fit déporter à Alma-Ata,
au Kazakhstan,
une république soviétique.
Lev Sedov, son fils,
avait choisi librement d'accompagner
ses parents en exil,
pour les soutenir.
Il devenait à 22 ans
le principal collaborateur
de son père.
Même en exil,
Trotsky travaillait dur.
Il écrivait des lettres
et des télégrammes adressés
à ses nombreux contacts
à Moscou
et dans les autres colonies
pénitentiaires.
Lev Sedov s'employait
à expédier ses messages
par tous les moyens possibles.
Les agents soviétiques ouvraient
le courrier
tout en le laissant circuler.
C'était un moyen
de surveiller l'opposant.
Mais au fil des mois,
les activités politiques de Trotsky
étaient devenues si intenses
que Staline y vit une menace.
Son rival
remettait ouvertement en cause
la légitimité
de son pouvoir.
A la fin de 1928,
Staline était convaincu
qu'il était dangereux pour lui
de garder Trotsky à Alma-Ata.
Le faire assassiner aurait rencontré
une opposition
de la part de certains membres
du bureau politique,
mais l'exiler
encore plus loin
pouvait être une solution.
...
Après 12 jours
de tergiversation,
Staline prit la décision
de déporter son rival
hors d'Union soviétique,
où il imaginait que sans argent
et sans soutien,
il ne pourrait plus agir.
...
Commença alors
pour Trotsky et Natalia
un exil interminable et chaotique
qui finirait par leur être fatal.
...
Au début des années 30,
l'Union soviétique
se trouvait dans une situation
économique et sociale
désastreuse.
Un échec, pour Staline,
qui devint dictatorial,
et rejetait toutes les fautes
sur les trotskistes.
...
C'est à ce moment-là
qu'il a déchu Trotsky
de sa nationalité soviétique.
Plus jamais il ne reverrait
sa terre natale.
Chants patriotiques en allemand
...
Il n'y avait pas qu'en Russie
que le régime s'était durci.
En janvier 1933,
Adolf Hitler avait été élu
chancelier du Reich.
...
Pour Trotsky,
qui était d'origine juive,
des nazis au pouvoir représentaient
un danger supplémentaire.
Durant les années 30,
le ciel s'était assombri
au-dessus de Trotsky.
Il avait d'abord perdu sa fille Nina
de tuberculose,
puis quelques mois plus tard,
son autre fille, Zina,
s'était suicidée au gaz à Berlin.
Trotsky accusa
officiellement Staline
d'avoir poussé sa fille
vers la mort.
Elle laissait un jeune fils,
Seva,
qui fut adopté par Lev Sedov,
le fils de Trotsky.
Musique mélancolique
Trotsky était sous le choc,
mais l'action le sauva.
Il multiplia les provocations,
refusant systématiquement
de renoncer
à ses activités politiques
et de se conformer aux règles
imposées par ses pays d'exil.
...
Entre 1932 et 1936,
Trotsky vécut
successivement
dans trois pays différents
dont il fut
chaque fois expulsé.
La Turquie,
la France
et la Norvège.
Soucieux de ne pas contrarier
Staline,
le chef suprême
de l'Union soviétique,
plus aucun pays ne voulait
de cet hôte encombrant.
Or, au milieu des années 30,
sa vie était de plus en plus menacée
par des services secrets russes
prêts à l'éliminer
dès que Staline le déciderait.
...
Après son recrutement,
Ramon Mercader fut envoyé
en Union soviétique pour y recevoir
une formation d'espion.
Il y était entraîné
par l'agent Kolstov,
l'amant de sa mère,
qui devint son mentor.
Kolstov n'aura de cesse
de le conditionner pour qu'il aille
au bout de sa mission.
Il restera dans son sillage
avec Caridad, jusqu'à Mexico.
-J'ai proposé à Kolstov
de passer un mois environ
à former Caridad et Ramon
aux techniques du renseignement
car ils étaient très novices
pour tout ce qui touchait
à des notions de base,
comme les techniques opérationnelles
ou les manières
de déjouer les filatures
et de changer d'aspects.
...
-En plus d'un entraînement
militaire spécifique,
Ramon devait apprendre
à être un autre homme,
un personnage entièrement fabriqué
par les agents de Moscou.
...
Désormais, il serait
Jacques Mornard, un citoyen belge,
journaliste sportif
et profitant joyeusement
de la vie grâce à l'argent
de sa famille.
Une fois installé
dans la peau de son personnage,
une nouvelle phase
pouvait commencer,
l'infiltration
des milieux trotskistes.
Un train siffle.
Trotsky était arrivé au Mexique
en janvier 1937.
Il avait 57 ans
et il lui restait
trois ans à vivre.
Musique mélancolique
...
Alors que Trotsky
et Natalia étaient
indésirables en Europe,
c'est Diego Rivera,
le grand peintre
de la révolution mexicaine,
et un fervent communiste,
qui leur avait obtenu
l'asile politique au Mexique.
A Mexico, ils s'étaient
installés à la Maison bleue,
la maison natale de Frida Kahlo,
l'épouse de Rivera.
Ils avaient été surpris
du bon accueil
qui leur avait été réservé.
Après avoir vécu 10 années noires,
dans la hantise permanente
d'être assassiné,
c'était, pour eux,
un moment de répit...
Un havre de paix et de vie.
...
Trotsky avait
de l'admiration
pour l'oeuvre de Rivera.
Ses fresques monumentales
rendaient
un vibrant hommage à l'histoire
et aux luttes
du peuple mexicain.
C'est au Mexique qu'avait eu lieu
la première grande révolte du monde,
prémisse à la révolution russe.
...
Le couple Rivera était
d'une originalité folle
et entrainait
dans le tourbillon de leur vie
le révolutionnaire russe
et sa femme.
Malgré une existence exotique
chez Diego et Frida,
Trotsky et Natalia
n'étaient jamais sereins.
Les nouvelles qui leur parvenaient
de Moscou étaient épouvantables.
Les purges lancées par Staline
depuis 1936 les hantaient.
Musique sombre
A Moscou, Staline liquidait
tous ceux qui le gênaient.
...
L'assassinat de son ami,
Sergueï Kirov,
avait été une aubaine pour lui.
Cela lui avait permis de désigner
des traîtres au parti
et de déclencher
une série de procès spectaculaires.
...
C'était une nouvelle phase
de la terreur stalinienne.
...
A la Loubianka,
le quartier général
de la police politique,
les cellules étaient
remplies d'accusés
qui étaient, la veille encore,
des dirigeants influents.
...
Terrorisés et acculés
par des preuves fabriquées,
ces anciens camarades de Lénine,
révolutionnaires
convaincus, étaient devenus
incapables de se défendre.
...
Le procureur Vychinski
se déchaînait contre eux.
...
Les condamnations à mort pleuvaient.
Les condamnés étaient
aussitôt fusillés.
...
En 1937, lors de la seconde vague
des grands procès de Moscou,
Trotsky et son fils, Lev Sedov,
furent accusés de vouloir
saboter l'Union soviétique,
et furent condamnés à mort
par contumace.
...
Quant au fils cadet
de Trotsky et de Natalia,
Sergueï,
qui vivait en Union soviétique,
il avait été déporté en Sibérie,
et assassiné.
Il avait 29 ans.
Sa famille,
ses amis,
Staline intensifiait la répression
anti-trotskiste,
et l'étau se resserrait
autour de Trotsky.
Musique de tension
...
Dès son arrivée à Mexico, en 1937,
Trotsky avait réorganisé
un bureau opérationnel
en engageant des secrétaires
et des traducteurs.
...
A la suite
de sa condamnation à mort,
il préparait activement ses réponses
aux graves accusations
portées contre lui par Staline.
...
Pour lui permettre
de se défendre publiquement,
son comité de soutien américain
eut l'idée d'organiser
un contre-procès.
Présidée par le philosophe
John Dewey,
cette commission était composée
d'intellectuels, de juristes,
et de politiciens américains.
-La commission Dewey se tint
à la Maison bleue au printemps 1937.
...
Durant 8 jours,
Trotsky fut interrogé sans relâche.
Une épreuve harassante
mais dont il sortit blanchi
des crimes dont l'accusait Staline.
...
La décision de cette commission
ne changeait rien
à la situation de Trotsky,
et de son fils, Lev Sedov,
qui restaient tous deux
dans le viseur de Staline.
En février 1938,
Lev Sedov, qui vivait à Paris,
se plaignit de douleurs au ventre.
Son nouveau collaborateur
le fit aussitôt transporter
dans une clinique dirigée
par un médecin russe.
Il fut opéré deux fois
avant de succomber.
Il avait 32 ans.
Après deux autopsies
et une enquête bâclée,
la police française concluait
à une mort naturelle.
Il semblait évident
que le gouvernement français
souhaitait ménager Staline.
Le fait que le nouveau collaborateur
du fils de Trotsky
fut en réalité
un agent stalinien
laissait planer bien
des interrogations sur ce drame.
Mais son rôle ne fut
jamais éclairci.
Musique sombre
La nouvelle de la mort de Lev Sedov
frappa Trotsky de plein fouet.
Il perdait non seulement un fils,
mais son collaborateur
le plus fiable.
...
Après la mort de ses deux filles,
et maintenant de ses deux fils,
Trotsky n'avait plus
qu'une idée en tête,
rapatrier au Mexique
son petit-fils, Seva.
...
A la Maison bleue,
les relations
entre Trotsky et Rivera
tournaient mal.
Les deux hommes s'opposaient
sur des questions politiques.
Rivera avait aussi été fâché
par la brève liaison
de Trotsky avec Frida.
Le secrétaire
et traducteur de Trotsky,
Jean van Heijenoort, témoigne.
-Frida n'hésitait pas,
un peu à la manière américaine,
à brandir le mot "love".
"All my love",
disait-elle à Trotsky
en le quittant.
Trotsky, apparemment,
fut pris au jeu.
Il se mit à lui écrire des lettres.
Il glissait la lettre dans un livre
et remettait le livre
à Frida, souvent en présence
d'autres personnes,
y compris Natalia ou Diego,
en lui recommandant de le lire.
Ceci se passait
quelque semaines après
la commission Dewey.
Fin juin,
la situation devint telle,
que ceux qui se trouvaient
tout près de Trotsky
commençaient à s'inquiéter.
Musique douce
...
-Rivera coupa brutalement les ponts
avec le révolutionnaire russe.
En perdant la protection du peintre,
Trotsky devenait plus vulnérable
que jamais.
Le danger se rapprochait
de jour en jour.
En juin 1938,
Ramon Mercader débarquait à Paris,
sous sa nouvelle identité,
Jacques Mornard.
Musique intrigante
...
Depuis sa formation d'espion
en Union soviétique,
il maîtrisait l'art du renseignement
et du camouflage.
La séduction était
l'un de ses atouts majeurs.
Les services secrets russes
en avaient fait une arme.
La cible s'appelait Sylvia Ageloff.
Elle avait été choisie
par l'équipe de Soudoplatov
car sa famille était
proche de Trotsky.
...
Le plan machiavélique avait commencé
quelques mois plus tôt,
quand une espionne soviétique
avait approché Sylvia
pour gagner son amitié.
Sa mission avait été
de la jeter dans les bras
de Jacques Mornard.
Musique légère
...
Celui qui se présentait à Sylvia
comme journaliste et photographe
était en réalité
l'agent soviétique Ramon Mercader.
...
Sylvia était facilement
tombée dans le piège.
Son nouveau fiancé,
qui menait grande vie,
l'emmenait
dans les restaurants à la mode,
les boîtes de nuit.
Elle était éblouie.
Suivant les ordres
de ses supérieurs,
il ne parlait jamais espagnol,
et faisait mine
de ne pas être intéressé
par la politique.
Mercader jouait avec Sylvia
la comédie de l'amour.
Il obéissait aux ordres.
...
Le plan fonctionnait parfaitement.
Ainsi, lorsque Sylvia
dut se rendre
au congrès
de la Quatrième Internationale,
c'est Jacques Mornard
qui la conduisit en voiture.
L'intégralité de ce congrès
avait été préparé par Trotsky
depuis son exil.
Il lançait un véritable
parti d'opposition.
C'était, pour lui,
un enjeu majeur.
Cela devait lui permettre
de relancer son mouvement
et son projet
de révolution mondiale.
Musique mystérieuse
Si Mornard n'assistait pas
au congrès de la Quatrième
Internationale,
les services secrets russes
avaient un autre agent infiltré.
Ils savaient
donc tout des projets de Trotsky.
...
Soudoplatov tissait
une toile d'araignée,
à l'échelle du monde,
pour qu'elle se referme,
le moment venu,
sur Trotsky.
...
A Mexico, au début de 1939,
Trotsky et Natalia
se séparaient définitivement
des Rivera.
...
Ils quittaient la Maison bleue
pour s'installer
à quelques rues de là,
avenue Vienna.
Menacés de toutes parts,
ils vivaient dans une maison
aux allures de forteresse.
...
Les allées et venues
étaient contrôlés,
Trotsky ne voulant rien changer
à ses habitudes.
Recevoir des partisans,
des hommes politiques
et des intellectuels,
lui restait vital.
...
-C'est avec les visiteurs
et les nouveaux venus
que Trotsky déployait
toute son amabilité.
Il parlait,
expliquait en faisant des gestes,
posait des questions,
et était, par moment,
vraiment charmant.
Et plus on avait
travaillé avec lui,
plus il était exigeant,
et plus il pouvait
devenir brusque.
La situation dans laquelle
nous vivions
avait sa part
dans cela.
Il fallait vivre
des années ensemble,
jour après jour,
dans un espace restreint,
avec des constantes mesures
de sécurité.
Tout était arrangé,
les visites, les sorties.
"Vous me traitez comme un objet",
me dit-il un jour.
...
-En perdant Rivera,
Trotsky se retrouvait privé
des ressources financières
du peintre.
Pour survivre, il écrivait
de nombreux articles de presse
et l'avance de droits d'auteur
pour sa biographie de Staline
complétait ses revenus.
Musique douce
...
En cette période noire,
quelques rayons de soleil
filtraient parfois dans sa vie.
La Quatrième Internationale
lui avait redonné espoir
dans l'avenir du trotskisme.
Il y avait aussi
des moments de bonheur,
comme l'arrivée à Mexico
de Seva,
au mois d'août 1939.
Seva donnait à Trotsky et à Natalia
une nouvelle raison de se battre.
Ils n'avaient pas revu
leur petit-fils depuis 6 ans.
C'est un jeune homme de 13 ans
qui arriva au Mexique.
Seva était l'un des rares survivants
de la famille.
Afin qu'il puisse s'intégrer
à son pays d'adoption,
Trotsky interdisait
qu'on lui parle en russe.
Il fut également rebaptisé Esteban.
...
Les Rosmer, amis du couple Trotsky,
qui avaient conduit Esteban
de France au Mexique,
séjournèrent 9 mois
à Mexico.
Une parenthèse amicale réparatrice
pour ceux dont tous les amis
et anciens collaborateurs
avaient été éliminés par Staline.
...
Malgré ce moment de trêve,
tout semblait indiquer
que Trotsky était en sursis.
...
L'imminence d'une guerre en Europe,
qu'il pressentait,
était une chose
qui l'inquiétait beaucoup.
Musique sombre
...
Le 23 août 1939,
la signature du pacte
germano-soviétique
anéantissait Trotsky.
...
Signée par Molotov,
chef de la diplomatie de Staline,
et von Ribbentrop,
ministre des Affaires étrangères
d'Hitler,
cette alliance était de mauvaise
augure pour Trotsky et l'Europe.
...
Le 1er septembre,
Hitler envahissait la Pologne.
Deux jours après,
la Grande-Bretagne et la France
déclaraient la guerre à l'Allemagne.
Vrombissement de moteurs
...
-Je me souviens d'avoir écouté
avec Trotsky,
sur un appareil d'ondes courtes,
la nouvelle du premier torpillage
d'un navire anglais
par un sous-marin allemand.
Tout cela avait un air de déjà-vu.
On sentait chez Trotsky
la lassitude de voir se répéter
une catastrophe
dont il avait été le témoin en 1914,
mais aussi la foi
que, dans quelques années,
la guerre amènerait
la révolution socialiste.
Détonations
...
-Alors qu'éclatait
la 2e Guerre mondiale
et que Staline devait diriger
son pays en guerre,
il ne pouvait pas se permettre
de garder en vie
son principal opposant.
Il donna l'ordre à Soudoplatov
de liquider Trotsky.
Soudoplatov et son équipe
réagirent aussitôt.
Mercader fut envoyé
à New York,
pour vivre chez Sylvia Ageloff,
ce qui devait lui permettre
de se rapprocher de Mexico,
et de Trotsky lui-même.
Quand Mercader expliqua à Sylvia
qu'il fuyait l'Europe
pour ne pas faire la guerre,
et avec un passeport canadien
acheté pour éviter d'être mobilisé,
elle le crut sur parole.
Et quand il partit au Mexique
pour "affaires",
Sylvia promit de l'y rejoindre.
Musique douce
...
Lorsque Sylvia vint le rejoindre
à Mexico au début de 1940,
elle fut aussitôt reçue
chez Trotsky et Natalia,
où elle était très appréciée.
...
Elle s'y rendait régulièrement.
Mercader la conduisait en voiture.
Il ne demandait jamais
à entrer dans la propriété,
arguant qu'une rencontre
avec le révolutionnaire russe
ne l'intéressait pas.
...
Peu à peu,
les gardes s'habituaient
à voir ce garçon sympathique
et serviable.
Mercader se lia même
avec l'un d'entre eux,
un jeune trotskiste américain
du nom de Robert Sheldon Harte.
Lorsqu'en mars,
Sylvia rentra chez elle, à New York,
Mercader n'avait plus besoin d'elle
pour approcher Trotsky.
Ce n'était plus
qu'une question de temps.
Mais Staline était pressé.
Il lui fallait absolument réduire
Trotsky au silence.
Pour répondre à l'impatience
de Staline,
Soudoplatov décida
de lancer une attaque à Mexico.
Musique sombre
...
Dans la nuit du 23 au 24 mai 1940,
vers 5h du matin,
une vingtaine d'hommes
armés jusqu'aux dents prend d'assaut
la maison de Trotsky.
Dans leur chambre,
le révolutionnaire et son épouse
sont endormis.
Leur petit-fils, Seva, dort
dans la chambre attenante.
Soudain retentit une série
de coups de feu en rafale.
Les tireurs inondent littéralement
de balles
les deux chambres à coucher.
La fusillade dure
de longues secondes.
Les gardes parviennent
à faire fuir les assaillants.
Trotsky, Natalia et Seva
sortent de l'attaque
en état de choc,
mais indemnes.
Natalia a protégé Trotsky
en l'abritant sous le lit.
L'affaire a un grand retentissement.
Trotsky est accusé
par ses détracteurs
d'avoir mis en scène cet attentat
pour faire parler de lui.
Mais l'enquête de la police
s'oriente
vers le peintre mexicain
David Alfaro Siqueiros.
Siqueiros est un stalinien
convaincu, et un tueur.
Il a combattu
durant la guerre d'Espagne
dans les rangs des républicains.
Malgré l'arrestation de Siqueiros
et de ses complices,
cette affaire conserve
des zones d'ombre.
L'une d'elle touche particulièrement
Trotsky,
car elle met en cause
l'un de ses proches collaborateurs.
Les assaillants sont entrés
facilement dans la maison.
L'homme qui leur a ouvert
est Robert Sheldon Harte,
le garde américain,
lié à Mercader.
Contrairement à la police mexicaine,
Trotsky refuse catégoriquement
de le considérer comme un traître.
Quand le corps de Harte est retrouvé
dans la banlieue de Mexico
avec deux balles dans la tête,
il est bouleversé.
Attaque mal préparée
ou simulacre d'attentat,
destiné à intimider Trotsky
et son entourage ?
Une atmosphère lourde plane
désormais sur la Casa Viena.
Trotsky sait que Staline enverra
d'autres tueurs pour l'éliminer.
Musique sombre
Craignant une nouvelle attaque,
la maison est sécurisée.
Les murs d'enceinte sont rehaussés,
de nouvelles tourelles construites.
A l'intérieur,
on équipe chaque pièce
d'une porte blindée,
et des gardes supplémentaires
sont engagés.
Musique douce
La terre d'exil du révolutionnaire
se rétrécissait toujours plus.
Malgré les risques,
il refuse de se laisser enfermer.
Cédant à sa passion
pour les cactus,
il s'offre encore quelques escapades
dans les montagnes désertes.
-La vie est belle.
Que les générations futures
la nettoient de tout mal,
de toute oppression
et de toute violence
et en jouissent pleinement.
...
Musique sombre
-Après l'échec
d'un premier attentat,
qui a mis Staline hors de lui,
Soudoplatov actionne l'agent préparé
spécialement pour tuer Trotsky,
Ramon Mercader.
...
Mercader n'était jamais entré
dans la résidence de Trotsky
avant l'attentat manqué,
mais 3 jours
après cette attaque,
il y fait son entrée
pour la première fois.
...
Trotsky et Natalia l'ont invité
à prendre le thé.
Ils souhaitent rencontrer le fiancé
de leur amie Sylvia Ageloff.
Mercader accepte l'invitation.
Il se montre curieux
de connaître Trotsky
et désireux d'écrire des articles
sur l'état du monde.
...
La rencontre se passe agréablement.
Il sera réinvité à la Casa Viena.
Il commence à rendre des services,
comme conduire les Rosmer,
les amis du couple Trotsky,
de Mexico à Veracruz.
Un voyage de 600 km,
mais il est prêt à tout
pour approcher Trotsky.
Après avoir manipulé Sylvia,
il séduisait l'entourage
du révolutionnaire :
ses gardes,
ses amis, son petit-fils.
Ensuite,
il disparaît un mois entier.
Sa disparition n'éveille
aucun soupçon.
C'est un homme d'affaires,
il était normal qu'il voyage.
De ce mois d'absence,
on ne sait pas grand-chose
du parcours de Mercader,
mais il est certain
qu'il préparait activement
son action contre Trotsky.
Soutenu dans sa mission
par sa mère Caridad
et par son mentor Kotov,
présents tous deux
dans la capitale mexicaine
pour assurer la logistique
de l'opération.
-Un peu plus tard,
Kotov devait me dire
que Ramon Mercader était prêt
à accomplir sa mission,
confiant dans son entraînement
de guérillero, en Espagne.
Pendant la guerre,
il ne s'était pas contenté
de se servir d'un fusil,
il avait combattu
au corps à corps,
armé d'un couteau.
Sa préparation lui permettait
d'utiliser trois moyens :
tuer Trotsky d'un coup de feu,
le poignarder
ou le battre à mort.
Caridad donna sa bénédiction
à son fils.
Musique sombre
...
-Le 20 août 1940,
lorsque Ramon Mercader traverse
le jardin de la Casa Viena,
il se sent nerveux.
Il vient présenter à Trotsky
la nouvelle version
d'un article qu'il a écrit.
Le révolutionnaire avait rejeté
la première,
la trouvant mal écrite et confuse.
Mercader s'était senti vexé.
Trotsky est occupé
à soigner ses animaux
quand Mercader le rejoint.
De loin, Natalia remarque
les deux hommes
en train de discuter.
Elle trouve étrange
que Mercader ait une gabardine
en plein mois d'août.
Trotsky et Natalia commencent
à se méfier de ce garçon,
trop mystérieux,
et envisagent
de se renseigner sur son compte.
Mais ce jour-là,
Trotsky accepte quand même
de le recevoir dans son bureau.
Ensuite, tout se passe très vite.
Alors que Trotsky se penche
sur le texte,
Mercader lui fracasse le crâne
avec le piolet
qu'il avait caché sous sa gabardine.
Le crâne enfoncé
et couvert de sang,
Trotsky mord son agresseur
pour l'empêcher de frapper encore.
Dans un ultime sursaut de vie,
il parvient même à se relever
et à sortir
de son bureau.
Il ordonne à ses gardes
de cesser de violenter Mercader,
qu'ils ont blessé.
"Il ne faut pas le tuer,
il faut qu'il parle !"
Sirène de police
Dans l'ambulance qui le conduit
à l'hôpital,
Trotsky est encore conscient.
Malgré les efforts du chirurgien
qui l'opère pendant
plusieurs heures,
il chemine vers la mort.
La lame du piolet s'est enfoncée
de 7 cm et a causé
des dommages irréparables.
Léon Trotsky meurt
le lendemain de l'attaque,
le 21 août 1940.
Il avait 60 ans.
C'était le point final
de l'opération Canard.
Staline avait gagné.
Bien des années plus tard,
les détails de cet événement
sont restés intacts
dans la mémoire d'Esteban Volkov,
le petit-fils de Trotsky,
le survivant de cette famille
décimée par Staline.
-Je revenais de l'école.
Quand je me suis approché
de la maison,
j'ai eu une sensation d'angoisse.
Je sentais que quelque chose
d'anormal était arrivée.
Il y avait des gens dans la rue,
une voiture était arrêtée.
J'ai accéléré mon pas
et je suis rentré.
Et alors là, j'ai vu
que tout le monde était bouleversé,
que quelque chose
de grave venait d'arriver.
Ma première...
Ma première impression,
c'était Mercader,
au milieu du jardin,
qui était arrêté par des policiers.
Il était dans un état
tout à fait... défait.
Il pleurait, criait, gémissait.
Jamais je n'avais vu
un être humain dans un tel état.
Le désarroi...
Je ne savais pas,
je ne comprenais pas
ce qu'il faisait,
cet ami, ce mari de Sylvia,
ce qu'il faisait là.
Après, quand je suis entré
dans la bibliothèque,
j'ai vu qu'il était vraiment blessé,
dans la chambre d'à côté.
D'ailleurs,
ils ne m'ont pas laissé entrer.
Lui-même, encore blessé,
il a donné comme instruction
"Le garçon,
Seva ne doit pas avoir ça."
-Mercader n'a pas pu fuir,
comme le prévoyait le plan.
Caridad et Kotov,
qui l'attendaient dans une voiture,
ont finalement été obligés
de l'abandonner derrière eux.
Il déclare aux policiers
s'appeler Jacques Mornard
et être citoyen belge,
une version
qui ne changera jamais.
Sa véritable identité
ne sera découverte
que 10 ans plus tard.
Dans sa poche,
la police retrouve une lettre
expliquant les mobiles de son acte.
-Il était important
de pouvoir avancer
une raison pour l'acte
qui devait discréditer
l'image de Trotsky
et de son mouvement.
L'assassinat devait prendre l'aspect
d'une vengeance
de Mercader contre Trotsky,
qui était supposé
avoir empêché Sylvia Ageloff
de l'épouser.
Si on l'arrêtait,
Mercader devait prétendre
que Trotsky avait cherché
à l'intégrer à un groupe
terroriste international
dont l'objectif était
d'assassiner Staline
et d'autres dirigeants soviétiques.
Musique dramatique
...
-Les Mexicains réservent
un bel hommage à Trotsky.
Une foule impressionnante défile
devant sa dépouille,
et plus de 200 000 personnes
accompagnent son cortège funèbre
à travers la ville de Mexico.
...
Si la nouvelle de la mort
du révolutionnaire russe
Léon Trotsky fait le tour du monde,
l'actualité reste dominée
par la guerre en Europe.
...
Après avoir fini ses jours
en France en 1962,
les cendres de Natalia
ont rejoint celles de Trotsky.
Tous deux reposent loin de Moscou,
dans leur maison
du quartier de Coyoacan, à Mexico.
Ramon Mercader est condamné
à 20 ans de prison,
la peine maximale au Mexique.
Durant tout ce temps,
les services spéciaux de Soudoplatov
lui ont assuré
une détention vivable.
Après avoir poussé son fils
à tuer Trotsky,
Caridad Mercader fit
de nombreuses tentatives
pour le faire libérer.
Toutes échouèrent.
Elle mourut à Paris en 1975,
sous un portrait de Staline.
Ramon Mercader reçut,
à sa sortie de prison,
le titre de héros
de l'Union soviétique,
mais en toute discrétion.
Il resterait à jamais
un homme de l'ombre.
Il mourut d'un cancer
à La Havane, en 1978,
à l'âge de 65 ans.
Il avait confié
n'avoir jamais oublié
le cri poussé par Trotsky
lorsque le piolet
lui fendit le crâne.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
...